[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700,000 words the Bible can generate a
lot of questions if you'd like answers
to your Bible questions you've come to
the right place now here's your host
Pastor Doug bachelor president and
speaker of amazing
facts welcome listening friends to Bible
answers live and we're so glad that
you've tuned in for a fresh installment
of answering Bible questions if you have
a question we have lines open right now
just pick up your phone of course it's a
free phone call in North America you can
also even call in on the internet around
the world the number 800 God says that's
800 463
7297 one more time 800
46372 N7 my name is Doug Bachelor and my
name is Sean Ross good evening friends
and Pasad Doug let's begin the program
with prayer dear father we thank you
that we're able to take a few moments
and open up your word and study together
this evening and we ask for your special
blessing to be with us be with those
listening wherever they might be and
lead us Lord into clear understanding of
the Bible for we ask this in jesus' name
amen
amen well Pastor D you open up by uh
sharing some interesting facts about uh
I've got a fact for you
now it's called U it's about Liquid
Paper back in the 1950s Betty Nesmith
had a good secretarial job at a Dallas
Bank this was when she noticed that
there was a problem that intrigued her
before the days of digital word
processors correcting a typing error was
a difficult and messy business she
thought there must be a better way
having some art experience she knew that
artists often painted over their errors
at home Betty put some white water-based
paint in a little bottle with a small
paintbrush and she took her simple
invention to the office it worked
perfectly so for 5 years Betty quietly
used her white correction paint to cover
typing mistakes even though some bosses
frowned on the practice soon all the
secretaries in her building were using
what she then called mistake out with
some help from her son at the high
school chemistry te teacher they helped
improve the formula so that it would dry
more quickly it became so popular Betty
attempted to sell the product idea to
various companies including IBM but they
all turned her down in 1956 she began
selling her typewriter correction fluid
out of the kitchen later expanding to a
portable metal building in her backyard
as the product became an indispensable
tool to the secretarial trade she formed
her own company and changed the name to
Liquid Paper By 1979 her company
employed 200 people and made 25 million
bottles of liquid paper for each year
this is when the Gillette company bought
Betty's company for $4
47.5 million I guess it turns out a
simple invention to cover mistakes was a
very popular idea and don't you wish
there was an invention that would help
us cover the mistakes of life or maybe
there is you know Pastor Doug there is
and that's uh probably a free offer that
we're going to be talking about today
that talks about how a person can be
forgiven where the sins of life can be
covered you know there's some scriptures
in in Isaiah 1:18 it says come now let
us reason together says the Lord though
your sins are like Scarlet they'll be
white as snow then you can go to
Revelation 7:14 and here it's talking
about those who are saved out of the
Great Tribulation it says they have
washed their robes and made them white
in the blood of the lamb and so there is
in the gospel it tells us about
something that helps us wash away the
mistakes of life and the sins of life
and we have a book that highlight we do
have the book is entitled baptism is it
really necessary and I'm reminded of
what the people said when Peter was
preaching and they were convicted and
they said what shall we do to be saved
and Peter said well repent and be
baptized well baptism is it really
necessary for the Christian today while
this book gets into that subject and
explains how we can have our sins washed
away and how baptism is connected with
that it's our free offer for today if
you'd like to receive it just give us a
call on our resource phone number that
number is
8835 6747
again that number is
6747 and you can ask for the book called
baptism is it really necessary and we'll
be happy to send it to anybody who calls
and asks all right what do we have for
the phones if people are calling in by
the way we do still have two lines open
if you want to call in with your Bible
question
7297 first caller this evening is
jaspine listening in Louisiana jasine
welcome to the
program hello Pastor evening get real
close to your phone okay and your
question hear better now I do hear you a
little better okay thank you both thank
you both for your Myster my question
tonight is uh um I've always thought
that the world was populated in all the
different parts um by Adam and Eve maybe
through uh like a Pangia kind of
Continental structure uhuh After the
flood uh that you know they were
separated but I was thinking that as we
all descend from shemam and jith how did
all the different areas uh get populated
and why were those kingdoms uh like in
the Americas and in the Chinese
dynasties not mentioned in um like
Daniel 2 for instance all right well
good question uh first of all you are
correct that the world's Nations the
continents were populated following the
Tower of Babel by the descendants of
Noah and um you know there have been
some studies on human migration that has
been done by National Geographic where
they track DNA and it's a very
interesting and it seems to be a fairly
precise uh science um and they're
they're seeing now that for instance the
Americas um the original people most of
them some came from Polynesia to South
America it's interesting they see that a
few boats evidently made it but most
most of them came in from Mongolia
across the baring straet um you know the
theory is that when shortly after the
flood there was something of an ice age
and they were able to cross there uh
either by foot or a very short jaunt in
a boat and um the reason that Daniel
chapter 2 when it talks about the
primary kingdoms being Babylon Meo
Persia Greece and Rome Daniel 2 is only
dealing with the kingdoms of the world
and the empires
that occupied God's people namely Israel
gotta so Babylon Meo Persia Greece Rome
all occupied God's people and so they're
mentioned in scripture in a specific way
of course there were great Empires among
the Aztecs and the Incas and the Chinese
and and others but they're not mentioned
because they had at that time no direct
impact on the nation of
Israel great yeah that makes a lot of
sense hey well we appreciate your
calling in and you know we do have a
timeline on that talks about some of the
different kingdoms and if you type in
bible.com bible.com that'll take you to
the amazing facts Bible History timeline
it's a great study tool a lot of people
have saved it in their favorites and
they go there again and again I use it I
believe Daniel chapter 2 is also there
you look up the different kingdoms
Babylon mea Persia Greece Rome it's all
put in the timeline and then some of the
other things that we read about in the
Bible how it all connected together so
just a great resource Bible
history.com and that'll give you more
information our next call is Marie
listening from Alberta Marie welcome to
the program yes hi there hi Pastor Doug
I I have a three-part question for you
can you hear me yes loud and clear okay
um can you explain exactly what is God's
grace and does it replace God's holy
Sabbath and the moral uh and the moral
law
uh and uh where in the Bible does it say
we can pick and choose the Ten
Commandments okay well first of all
God's grace is the pardoning uh
Salvation of the Lord where we receive
unmar or undeserved favor from God for
both pardon and power people always
think about God's grace as his winking
at our weakness but God's grace also o
supplies he gives us power to do his
will and that's part of his grace as
well um the moral law and for those
listening moral law is sometimes called
the decalogue is another term for the
Ten Commandments um and of course all of
the Ten Commandments are not suggestions
they're not optional God does not give a
10 or 20% discount on the Ten
Commandments He commands us to keep them
all that would include the fourth
Commandment which is a Sabbath that um
Marie was just asking about and um we're
we're not told anywhere that we get to
pick and choose I mean these are the
Commandments of God and um sin is
according to the New Testament sin is
the transgression of God's law so when
we lie it is a sin when we steal when we
murder adultery those are sins and so
you know we're never allowed to break
God's law without being in Jeopardy of
sin and the penalty for sin is death so
that's why we need God's forgiving Grace
and his grace to give us power to live
new lives to repent of our sins and to
have our sins washed in the blood of the
lamb as we mentioned
earlier we appreciate that you know we
do have a book we'll send you a free
copy called The Riches of his grace
Marie talks about the grace of God and
if you call the resource number they'll
send you a free copy the number to call
is 8835 6747 you can ask the book called
The Riches of his grace we'll be happy
to send that to you Maria or anybody who
calls and asks again that number is
6747 if you have a Bible question our
phone line here to the studio is
7297 our next call is Fred listening
from Connecticut Fred welcome to the
program yes uh good evening even I
wanted to ask you how much you know
about the lunar
Sabbath well in the Bible of course at
creation
um it tells us that the seventh day was
the Sabbath he created the world in six
days he made one more day for his
special appointment God in the beginning
it says he blessed that day hallowed it
and what God did he made for man Genesis
said the Sabbath I'm sorry Jesus said
the Sabbath was made for man God didn't
make it for himself he made it to be a
blessing to man um then years later
during the ceremonial laws at the
beginning of every uh month they had
they called the new moon their months
were divided by the moon back then
that's where we get the word for moon it
was or the word for month rather and uh
they used to have a new moon Sabbath
well that could come on a different day
of the week just like you know the
calendar dates fall on different days of
the week so the lunar sabbaths did not
always line up with the weekly Sabbath
the lunar Sabbath was never treated as
importantly as the weekly Sabbath of the
Ten Commandments it was was more part of
the ceremonial law and you find it was
nailed to the cross when you read in let
me see Colossians chapter 2 don't let
anyone judge you in regard to U Sabbath
days which are shadows of things to come
he's talking about the ceremonial
sabbaths and feast days that were part
of that ceremonial law so uh we do have
a book that talks about feast days and
sabbaths Fred we can send you a free
copy would you like yes I've called the
resource line
before all right well if you like that
we would be happy to send it to you ask
you read it and then share it with a
friend the number to call for that is
800 83567 47 that is the resource phone
line just ask for the book called feast
days and sabbaths we'll be Happ to send
that to anybody who calls and asks thank
you for your call Fred our next caller
is uh Elden listening from Nevada Elden
welcome to the
program yes hello this is gy from Las
Vegas peace and blessings to both of you
thank you thank you for
calling uh Pastor Doug I have a question
for you um and it's 1 Timothy 4: 3-5
where Timothy warns of religious leaders
that tell you what to eat and what not
to eat and calling unclean what God has
created can you possibly um give a
little bit more information on that sure
yeah I'd like to actually read the
verses before to get the context so if
you look in 1 Timothy CH 4 it says the
spirit speaks expressly saying that in
the latter times some will depart from
the faith giving heed to deceiving
spirits and doctrines of devils speaking
lies and hypocrisy having their own
conscience seared with a hot iron
forbidding to marry all right so right
away it's telling us about a group that
would forbid some of its people to marry
well there are some churches that forbid
their pastor
to Mary and commanding to abstain from
foods which God created to be received
with Thanksgiving of them that know and
believe the truth meaning that uh first
of all Paul dealt with people in his day
there were Jewish leaders that were
saying that
um you could not eat food that God said
was clean because it had been offered to
a pagan God and Paul said the idol is
nothing and um you know if someone
offers their goat or their sheep or
their chicken to an idol before they
butcher it and you buy it at the meat
market says it doesn't mean that you're
worshiping that God be kind of like uh a
church telling their members you can't
eat at that Chinese restaurant because
they got a little statue of Buddha by
the cash register and you know some
people take it that far and uh but
there's also a church that says on
certain days of the week you can and
can't eat fish whether it's clean or not
biblically was not the issue it says
they're they're saying you can't eat
things that God says you can't
eat and um so you know I think that we
all know there was a church that sort of
ruled Europe for about uh 12200 years
they told their priests they could not
marry they said that you could eat fish
on some days and not on other days and
and uh it fulfills this prediction
pretty
accurately
okay so that make sense yeah yes it does
uh I I was a little bit confused I spoke
to uh to a Jew uh regarding the Mosaic
law and I asked him about kosher laws
and he said uh he asked me are you
Jewish I said no I'm I'm a gentile he
said well you're a gentile you can eat
whatever you want but he said we're
Jewish and the Mosaic law was given to
Jews only and to and not to the Gentiles
well he's mistaken because you the
difference between clean and unclean
food was clearly given to Gentiles and
my my argument for that would be Noah
who lived long before Abraham and long
before circumcision was told of course
everybody listening to my voice right
now in case you don't know it you're
related to Noah Noah was told to take on
the ark the clean Animals by sevens and
the unclean Animals by two so God made a
distinction between clean and
unclean for everybody it goes all the
way back and a reason for that
distinction that goes all the way back
to um well right after the fall is that
the sacrificial system was instituted
right after Adam and Eve sinned and at
that point a distinction was made
between what animals could be sacrificed
and what animals couldn't be sacrificed
and uh that principle is in
establishment from Way Before the Flood
yeah so anyway uh yeah I respectfully
even though I am half Jewish I
respectfully disagree with a Jew that
said that God doesn't care what Gentiles
eat I don't know why God would care that
Jews are holy and not care that other
people are holy anyway hey thank you
very much Alden for your question and we
do have a booklet if you've not seen it
before and it's called God's Health Plan
talks about the clean and the unclean
food and where that's mentioned in the
Bible the number to call is 800 835 6747
you can ask for the study guide call
God's free health plan we'll be happy to
send this to anybody who calls and asks
again that number is
8835 674 47 our next caller that we have
is Joe listening from riolinda
California Joe welcome to the
program thank you uh my question has to
do with Sabbath okay it's it was
designed to have rest and relaxation for
that for that period of time uh why
would not going to a movie be considered
relaxing well the Sabbath is more than
just rest and relaxation if you look in
Leviticus 23 it call calls the Sabbath a
holy
convocation and uh that means it's a
time for us to come together to worship
and in Isaiah is at 58 where God says
not speaking your own words or finding
your own pleasure and so we're to set
aside that time from worldly pleasure
now if a person is watching uh Christian
programming like sermons on Sabbath
sometimes we turn on couple of Christian
channels on Sabbath and we'll listen to
other preachers and that's you know I
think consistent with the something holy
yeah the verse you're thinking of is
Isaiah
58:13 so that would be my response to
that Joe is you know would Jesus be
going to a movie to watch Terminator on
Sabbath probably not and you know the
Bible talks about buying and selling and
so for the typical theater you also have
to buy a ticket and and it says on
Sabbath we shouldn't be getting involved
in merchandising buying and selling and
and so I just think for a number of
reasons that would probably not be
consistent with good Sabbath keeping
there's a lot of other good ways to rest
though oh
yeah that was just one of my questions
thank you all right hey appreciate that
Joe good question next call is uh Floyd
listening from Antelope California Floyd
Welcome to the
program thank
you my question is about 30 years ago I
was going to Revelation SAR
yeah and the teacher in the Revelation
seminar he would take a match and light
it and burn it this was when they had to
read a Revelation bible they gave those
Bibles away with the
Revelation now after they stopped giving
the red one they start giving brown ones
away I really like the red one better
because it had more commentary in it but
he would like to match and said when it
burn it burns up so when a person would
go to hell they wouldn't burn forever
that they would burn up but the Bible
says that we are corruptible so
corruptible things would burn like being
cremated now you would burn to ashes but
then when you rais from the
dead then you you the body will be
Incorruptible so if it's Incorruptible
how could it burn up into ashes all
right a resurrected body all right good
question uh first of all the promise is
that the saved and the says 1
Corinthians 15 it is only the saved that
come out of the graves with
Incorruptible bodies there's no promise
that the wicked are going to be raised
with Incorruptible bodies secondly if
you read in Malachi CH 4 it says behold
the day comes that will burn as an oven
and all the proud and all that do
wickedly will be stubble the day that
comes will burn them up it will leave
them neither root nor
Branch but unto you that fear my name
shall the son of righteousness arise
with healing his wings and you will go
forth and tread upon the wicked for they
will be ashes Under The Souls of your
feet and so the wicked there's no
question there's a number of scriptures
that say the wicked become ashes uh and
again it says that uhu Revelation 20
they are
consumed uh it tells us the Wicked Will
consume away into smoke they are burnt
up so there's quite a few verses that
say the wicked after their judgment
every man is punished there is a lake of
fire we don't question Hellfire that's
pretty clear but as far as the time
their last conscious thought is sort of
an eternal thought that they're dying in
this fire and so you know it's frozen in
time but as far as God having a torture
chamber a billion years from now where
people are still burning the Bible
doesn't teach that Bible says that all
things are made new there's no more pain
no more sorrow no more
crying uh Sinners are not
immortalized so um that yeah we've got a
whole lesson on that Floyd if you'd like
us to send you a
copy okay pastor R give you the number
it's called the lesson's called is the
devil in charge of Hell the number to
call is 800 say that again it's called
the lesson is called is the devil in
charge of hell that's the name of the
the lesson is the devil in charge of
hell and we'll be happy to send that to
anybody who calls an ask the number is
8835 6747 just ask the study guide
called is the devil in charge of hell
and if you have access to the worldwide
web and it seems nowadays nobody does
not have access to the worldwide web we
do have a um website dedicated to the
Bible truth of hell it's called
helltruth.com it's got a lot of
scriptures there some video you can
watch on sermons related to the subject
uh anything more you'd want to know
about the subject of Hell in the Bible
it's there on that website helltruth.com
so encourage you to take a look at that
thank you for your call Floyd our next
caller is Jerry listening in Oregon
Jerry welcome to the
program yes uh good after good evening
pastors Ross and Pat and Bachelor uh I
was very touched by the uh the family
members of that uh Charleston prayer
meeting shooting who forgave that man
who did the shooting and that kind of
got me to thinking uh normally when when
and they they they forgive this man and
now when you here in court to give your
victim impact statement should you under
those conditions plead for clemency for
this person and if you do should the
jury consider it given Leviticus 20 uh
244 verse 17 it says for he who takes
another man's life shall surely be put
to death now that's a good question
there in some cases when uh family
members can make a state statement
before sentencing I've actually been to
sentencings like that sometimes it's in
the hands of a jury and sometimes it's
in the hand of a judge usually it's in
the hands of a judge um and frequently
the law or a plea bargain has already
been made before families make their
statements but it is the the judge does
have the discretion if someone for
instance is going to get the death
penalty and the family says we forgive
this person please please forgive them
and maybe give them life or something
and that may factor in the judge's
decision if he's you know hanging in the
balance um but uh you know there are
clear laws the judges need to follow no
matter what a person might say if you go
to the police and you say I realize this
person stole my car and I just want to
forgive them well you may not file for
civil damages but they're still going to
prosecute this person for the felony of
stealing a car uh so because they've
broken a law that you know other people
will be threatened
by um so yeah you know it's one thing to
forgive a person and say I have no
malice towards you but that doesn't
always mean they should not pay any kind
of penalty for their crime because if
everybody forgives everybody who commits
a crime pretty soon criminals are EMB
Bolen and um but that's uh it's
remarkable when people can say that they
forgive when someone is murdered a loved
one that that takes a Supernatural
forgiveness hey thank you very much
Jerry we appreciate that and uh I've got
a sermon online that you might enjoy
it's called 70 time 7 it talks about
forgiveness 70 time
7 our next call is Terry listening from
uh Nevada Terry welcome to the program
hi my um my question is uh when we all
die and go to heaven isn't it temporary
and then don't we come and rain on Earth
with Jesus Christ on the new in the new
Earth yes well at that point good
question the time that we live in the
city of God is limited the Bible says we
live in reign with God for a thousand
years and then the New Jerusalem
descends down to earth and at that point
Heaven basically is brought to Earth or
Paradise the New Jerusalem uh comes down
to earth the tree of life is in the new
Earth uh we will be living in a state of
paradise and Bliss the Bible says that
his right hand are Pleasures forever
more I think that's Psalm 16 and so
Heaven as we know it you know this
wonderful world of Eternity will be
moved to the Earth uh we won't be out in
space where the uh capital of God's
universe is that's why Jesus says in
Matthew uh blessed are the meek for they
shall inherit the earth yeah not the
Earth as we know it now but the Earth
recreated and restored after that 1,000
years yeah Bible says I I beheld a new
heavens and a new Earth it says that in
Revelation and second Peter chapter 3
also talks about that hey thank you very
much Terry uh we're just going to run
out of time right now for this first
half of the program we're not going away
we've got the best yet to come by the
way we do have a couple of phone lines
open if you want to give us a call with
your Bible question that number is 800
God says 800
46372 N7 also want to remind you that a
lot of the amazing facts material can be
explored and enjoyed online a very
popular website is the Amazing Facts
website and you'll see we have free
books there Bible studies you can
download for free lots of videos and
sermons for free you know we just
operate by faith we offer a lot of free
material and um you can even go to
YouTube we have a YouTube channel we had
a Facebook Channel I think last week
we've had a million last month a million
people have gone to the amazing facts
Facebook Channel we'll be back in just a
moment
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live will
return in a
[Music]
moment amazing facts began in
1965 with a god inspired concept hello
this is Joe Cruz on the amazing facts
broadcast facts which affect you each
radio broadcast would begin with an
amazing fact from science nature or
history followed by a bible message that
touched the hearts of listeners from
every Walk of Life the program was an
instant success and the ministry soon
began expanding to include Bible lessons
in 1986 amazing facts added the medium
of Television to its growing Outreach
efforts offering so winning Evangelistic
messages for viewers around the world in
1994 Pastor Doug Bachelor assumed
leadership of the ministry adding the
Bible answers live call-in radio program
and new ministry TV programs began
airing on multiple networks around the
world for 50 years the driving vision of
amazing facts has been the Bold
proclamation of the Everlasting gospel
and with a team of evangelists circling
the globe and thousands of men and women
being trained through the amazing facts
Center of evangelism program AFCO
the ministry is helping God's Church see
a Rich Harvest of
souls amazing facts God's message our
[Music]
mission every Bible question you have
answered moves you one step closer to
the fullness of God's will for your life
so what are you waiting for get the
answers you need for a fuller richer
more confident life you're listening to
Bible answers
live this broadcast is a previously
recorded episode if you'd like answers
to your Bible related questions on the
air please call us next Sunday between
7:00 p.m. and 8:00 p.m. Pacific time to
receive any of the Bible resources
mentioned in this evening's program call
800 835
6747 once again that's 800 835
6747 now now let's join pastors Doug
Bachelor and Jean Ross for more Bible
answers
[Music]
live welcome back listening friends we
assume some have joined us along the way
as typically happens with radio if you
don't know you're listening to Bible
answers live this is a live
International interactive Bible study
program you can participate by just
listening as people call in these are
live questions that are coming in we
never know we don't prime or prompt
people what to ask and you can call in
with your Bible questions 800 God says
800 463
7297 we don't claim to have all the
answers but we look to the word together
we find a lot of them there my name is
Doug Bachelor my name is Johan Ross and
we going to go to the phone lines our
next caller is Noah listening from Cedar
Lake Michigan Noah you're on the air
with Pastor the
Doug hi hi Noah how old are you eight
eight years old bless your heart and
what's your Bible question
tonight my question is when lot was
going out of the city and he took his
wife and his two
daughters and his and the angels told
them not to look back and her and his
wife looked back how did lot know that
his wife turned into a p poar assault
good question and if she was walking
behind him he'd have to look back and
find out and then he would have turned
into a pillar of salt chances are that
he was wanting to be between the judged
cities and his family so I'm guessing
that he was in the back his wife and
daughters were just ahead of him and his
he saw his wife turn around and saw what
happened and bra broke his heart but he
needed to keep pressing on so that's the
only way I suppose that he could have
seen her she was either just to the side
or in front of him but lot didn't look
back or he would have been a pillar
assault and then again it's always
possible that the Holy Spirit when Moses
was writing the story The Angel just
told him what happened to Lot's wife and
he knew because he was divinely
told good question
Noah does that
help all right hey thank you for calling
in I'm trying to think what lesson we
could offer Noah I don't we don't really
have a lesson on
lot you know we do cold remember Lot's
wife we do have a book I think well we
got one also called last night on earth
they both they talk about that too yeah
we we've got a book called Remember
Lot's wife you you call our Resource
number we'll send you a free copy thank
you very much Noah the number to call
for anyone wanting to learn more about
that he 800 835 6747 you can ask for the
book called Remember Lot's wife just a
number of important lessons that we can
learn from that story our next caller is
um Michael listening in Florida Michael
welcome to the
program hi um hello past Ross and bachor
uh my question for tonight is about
Christians and dancing I I know that
there's plenty of uh dances and dance
styles out there that are rather you
know sensual and you know very
non-Christian and whatnot but I've heard
many a pastor and Many religious men say
well pretty much indicate that dancing
is something Christians shouldn't do at
all and one major verse I've heard
people say is uh um I think it's
Ecclesiastes where it says a time and in
place for everything yeah um a time in
season excuse me for everything and they
say that all you know these last days
where we should be focusing on
repentance and whatnot um it's not the
time for dancing or but I don't know
because that always seemed a bit strange
to me because uh I don't know like say
for instance if someone's wedding it's a
joyous occasion of two people coming
together that that would seem to be a
time or a season for for for dancing or
for for happiness and everything and
another thing that made it seem strange
to me was us the usual overlooking of
the verse in I believe 2 Samuel where it
says that David danced before the Lord
with all his might and I'm not sure I I
was wondering what your take is on that
well you can't escape the scripture and
I don't think we should try to say there
is a certain type of appropriate dance
when the children of Israel cross the
Red Sea Mariam led the women in a dance
of rejoicing now one thing you'll notice
right away is when Jeff's daughter came
to dance when David and Saul came back
from battle and the women came and did a
victory dance you have the women just
dancing with women uh and they're
they're doing more of a folk victory
dance it's a it's they're not dancing
with men um when you have the dance of
herodias daughter for King Herod that
was a seductive dance that you know like
a heram girl would do and um John the
Baptist lost his head so that obviously
was not a good context of a dance when
David danced before the Lord he was not
dancing with women he was doing just a
dance of clapping his hands and maybe
hitting a tambourine
and it was more of a a dance of
rejoicing so you can't say there's never
a time to do that um and as it says in
Ecclesiastes typically the dancing you
know 99% of the dancing that's done in
the world today is men with women and
they are the inappropriate kinds of
dance if a man wants to dance with his
wife uh and they're alone that might be
one thing but U you know I I just don't
see too many
examples uh a Jewish dance for instance
you'll notice the men dance with the men
the men will take the groom they'll put
him in the middle they will join hands
and they will dance in a circle around
him to celebrate the women will do the
same for the bride but the men are not
dancing with the women at an Orthodox
Jewish wedding those were the kind of
folk dances that happened biblically uh
yeah I don't know maybe I'm saying too
much does that make sense
yeah it makes sense I I figured that's
what I was really getting at because
it's like sometimes I've heard people
like criticize dancing at St wedding
reception at all no matter what it was
I'm not because I like I said in the
beginning my question like I know that
there's dances out there that are very
sensual and they're very yeah
inappropriate but I know sometimes when
people sweepingly generalize dancing Al
together as wrong it it just seemed
weird to me least you know um and you do
have examples of course where um
you know people are uh doing folk dances
and things like that and you know that
varies from country to Country and uh so
yeah you've got to just I think we have
to be careful to do all things that will
glorify God but hey I do appreciate your
question now we've got a lesson that
talks about in one of our study guides I
love that transforms I think that's what
it's called yeah I love the transforms
we've got a study guy that actually
talks about music and dancing and what
appropriate for a Christian and I think
you'll enjoy that Brian the number to
call is 800 83567 47 you can ask for the
study guide call Michael sorry yeah I
love that transform so we're happy to
send this to Michael or anyone who calls
and asks our next call is Janet
listening from Texas Janet welcome to
the
program hello hi Janet thanks for
waiting oh yeah ah glad to hear you on
the program it's been very interesting
tonight
I was uh wondering about speaking in
tongues is that really just for when
there's an interpreter in the church or
if that's a prayer language when you
just should be
praying well you know there is no
example in the Bible of anybody praying
in tongues there's not a single case of
it uh when okay so when uh you know some
people say when Jesus said Eli Eli
lakani he was praying in tongues but no
he that's he was just speaking in
Aramaic which was his language the gift
of tongues was when God poured out the
holy spirit in Acts chapter 2 he gave
the disciples the supernatural ability
to speak in the languages of these
visiting Jews from around the Roman
Empire they spoke like 16 different
languages are mentioned for the purpose
of preaching the gospel that is the gift
of tongues it was a miraculous ability
to speak in and languages tongues they
had formerly not known and that's what
you also have happening in Acts chapter
10 and Acts chapter
19 so uh what happens in a number of
churches today where people are speaking
in tongues they just stand up in church
and start to speak Paul is saying if you
don't have someone who is an interpreter
you know we have um visitors in our
church every week we had people from
other parts of the world this week if
someone should stand up in our church
and SP you know start to give a test
in another language well unless there
someone to translate this is what Paul
says in 1 Corinthians 14 doesn't do
anyone any good um so he said there
should be an interpreter or translator
there um we have a book on tongues we
can send you a free copy Janet and it's
simply called understanding tongues
we'll send you a free copy anyone out
there listening if you've had questions
about what is the gift of tongues and
we've all heard pastors on TV that kind
of launch off into speaking these
incoherent languages and you think did
the apostles do that did Jesus do that
what in the world are they doing if you
would like to know more about what is
the appropriate gift of tongues the
biblical gift of tongues and maybe a
little bit about some of the
counterfeits then you need to ask for
this book it's free understanding
tongues the number to call is 800 83567
47 you can ask for the book called
understanding tongues again that number
is 800 835 6747
or you can go to the Amazing Facts
website just amazingfacts.org and you
can type in the little search bar there
understanding tongues and you'll be able
to read the book for free right there
online our next caller is uh Elden and
uh he's calling back from Nevada uh
Elden welcome to the
program oh thank you uh and again thank
you for answering my first question I do
have a second question for you uh uh
this is regards to Revelations uh when
the an angel is showing John
visions and my understanding is uh
Revelations covers past present and
future situations and and so my
understanding is that uh the only humans
in heaven right now would be Moses
Elijah and Enoch so who are the martyrs
uh under the altar of God that are
begging for Revenge all right let me
read the verse for friends that are
listening if you go to Revelation
chapter 6
and you look in verse 9 it says he
opened the fifth seal now of course the
Seven Seals are obviously full of
symbols when you read them he opened the
fifth seal and I saw under the altar the
context of Revelation is taking place in
this Sanctuary setting chapter one you
got seven candlesticks and here you got
the altar which is the altar of prayer
and in chapter I think it's 11 they got
the uh Arc of the Covenant it says he um
The Souls of those who been slain for
the word of God and the testimony that
they held they cried with a loud voice
saying how long that they've been slain
for Jesus that's why we're calling the
martyrs how long oh Lord holy and true
until you judge and avenge our blood on
those who dwell on the earth then a
white robe was given to each of them and
it was said that they should rest a
little while longer so here these are
souls resting that means they're
sleeping and they should rest longer
until the number of their fellow
servants and their Brethren who should
be killed was completed this this is how
explaining a time of great persecution
it doesn't mean the souls started to
actually speak if you read in Genesis
when Cain killed Abel God says the blood
of your brother cries to me from the
ground well bre blood doesn't speak uh
that is a very clear symbolic phrase
that would mean Justice is crying out
for Vindication and so this is the the
lives of those who are slain for Jesus
called calling out for Vindication and
of course the fifth seal covers a time
of severe persecution That Came Upon
Bible believing Christians sometimes you
refer to this as the Dark Ages a period
of about 1260 years and for many of the
Believers who are suffering persecution
and many of their loved ones had been
killed uh they doubtless cried out how
long Lord are we going to suffer these
persecutions and so that's echoing the
experience of the Believers during that
time and the voice comes back uh when
not the time is not yet done uh there
was a certain prophecy related to this
that had to meet its fulfillment but the
Assurance was given that those who gave
their life as a testimony of their faith
they were promised eternal life where it
talks about a white robe being given
them so it's a very symbolic passage
here referring to uh 1260 years during
the Dark Ages yeah you would hope that
Souls don't wake up with a bad dream
crying and then go back to sleep right I
mean who would want to be that Soul it's
so it is a symbol and of course if the
souls were not wearing white robes and
they were given white robes what were
the souls wearing before they got the
white robes yeah it's a so it's it's
definitely symbolic and of course white
robes is symbolic as well of the
righteousness does that help a little
bit
Alden yes it does I really appreciate it
thank you thank you very much for your
call and your question and who do we
have lined up next Pastor the next call
is Jamies I think that's the way we
pronounce it from Huntsville
Alabama yeah good evening pastor
evening how are you doing I'm doing well
thank you thanks for taking my call my
question is about Zechariah the 11th
chapter and the 7eventh verse and I want
to know what the staff of favor and
Union represented and whether it was
prophetic or is talking about after
Exile boy you know this is a tough uh
passage let me read it to people who are
listen you talking about Zechariah
11:7 yes um
yeah hang on a second here you almost
need to read the whole chapter here and
he talks about these different staffs um
and it says here well I'll read verse
four thus says the Lord God feed the
flock for Slaughter whose owners
slaughter them and feel no guilt who
sell them and say blessed be the Lord
for I am rich and the Shepherds do not
pity them for I will no longer pity the
inhabitants of the land says the Lord
but indeed I will give everyone unto his
neighbor's hand and into the hand of his
king and the attack the land and I will
not deliver them from their hand so I
fed the flock for Slaughter in
particular the poor of the flock I took
for myself two staffs one I called
Beauty the other I called bonds and I
fed the flock and I dismissed the uh the
three Shepherds in one month my soul LOE
them and uh their soul also arbored me
and I'll said I'll not feed
you uh let what's dying die and what is
perishing perish let those that are left
each one eat each other's flesh and I
took my staff Beauty and cut it in two
that I might break the Covenant that i'
had made with all the peoples now the
two nations of Israel uh the Kingdom of
Israel was split into two parts you had
the southern Kingdom of Judah you had
the northern kingdom of the 10 tribes
better known as Israel they were both
judged because they turned to
idolatry and um you know I'm this sounds
a lot like
what the judgments that had come upon
Judah and Israel of course Zachariah is
prophesying after that so it's almost
like he's looking ahead I don't know
Pastor Ross I don't claim to understand
all of Zachariah I think it's clearly
symbolic as you refer to the two staffs
of the shepherd matter of fact it
actually mentions it where it talks
about these two has been Judah and
Israel and it's talking about judgment
that God allowed to come against these
two entities of course Israel was
conquered by the Assyrians Judah was
eventually conquered by the Babylonians
because of their apostasy and there was
great Slaughter when these nations came
and brought judgment against them and
yet there is the promise in Zachariah of
a Remnant being saved and from that
Remnant the Messiah would come so these
two staffs would represent Israel Judah
and the judgments that would come
against them because of their sins yeah
the kings were supposed to carry a staff
Shepherd David is we've talked there
prophecies talk about the staff of David
and he was a shepherd and U then you had
Kings of Israel and they're supposed to
care for the people but they didn't care
for them they just took care of
themselves and so judgment came that's
why you read in verse 17 woe to the
worthless Shepherd who leaves the flock
a sword shall be against his arm and
against his right eye that's pretty
clear just judgment will come on
Unfaithful Shepherds Jesus also told
Parables about that uh is it
James yes yeah so I don't know if that
helps a little or we just made matters
more cloudy but uh no it it it helped
that they was kind of looking back and
looking forward at the same time and
that was that's what I wasn't sure about
but that definitely helped all right he
well thank you very much you know what
you've done is you've made me want to go
home and look at the commentaries on
Zachariah me too I certainly don't know
it all yet I'm still learning thank you
thank you our next call is Greg
listening in Ohio Greg welcome to the
program good evening how are you this
evening doing better than we deserve how
can we help you
tonight well um I'm in a relationship
with a woman it's a dear friend of mine
for the last 40 years um uh she's a
widow her husband died and I've been
divorced through a state
marriage and we've been studying the
Bible and we're looking we want to be
biblically married but we don't want to
go through the government so we've been
studying the Bible and we cannot find in
the Bible anywhere it says what need to
do to be married well you can be married
you can be married in a
church by a pastor and get a license
that doesn't I mean what would be your
problem with getting a license a license
no I'm looking for a biblical definition
of
marriage well the Bible says that um man
and woman are joined together they
become one flesh uh but typically the
marriages were publicly recognized part
of the reason they were publicly a
public event is it basically told
everybody what I'm looking what I'm
looking for is which book chapter verse
in the Bible says what you need to do to
be
married well I give a verse one you know
the 10th commandment says Thou shallal
not covet thy neighbor's wife it's
pretty evident that if someone could
covet his neighbor's wife he would then
need to know that she was indeed married
to him so marriage
me how he became his
wife well you're not going to be able to
go back I can tell you where a wedding
took place it says God took Eve and gave
her to Adam and she became his wife uh
you're not going to have too many events
like that um you do have the first
miracle of Jesus that takes place at a
wedding that's right I was just to say
and Jesus tells Parables about what
weddings are MH okay and that would be
of course uh John chapter 2
so there is there is AB like baptism is
described in the Bible as being immersed
in water right
yeah okay
so uh but the Bible doesn't really
describe what marriage is except
for
what there's there's really no uh
biblical description for marriage except
for she's my wife right no they're they
always had you notice that before Joseph
married Mary it says they were betrothed
that means there had been a covenant
made and then in the Prophecies of Hosea
talks about the Covenant of marriage and
so there is a public Covenant where you
have witnesses and recognition and
commitment and all those things are
involved in a number of books in the
Bible talks about these weddings I hope
that helps a little bit uh Greg and U we
do have a book that talks about this in
more detail called marriage divorce and
remarriage and biblical princip
on the subject of marriage and we'll be
happy to send that to anyone who calls
and asks the number is 800 835
6747 and you can ask for the book
marriage divorce and remarriage our next
caller is Jack listening from Georgia
Jack welcome to the program you very
much uh that was a pretty good answer
you guys uh just did so well thank you
the uh I got a question I'm probably
going to muddle it up here a little bit
but uh in the millennial
rain when um we are uh
taken and we come back to rule and I'm
talking about the
saved um when we come back to rule with
Christ in the millennial reign with with
Jesus my understanding
is my first question is who are we
ruling over with Jesus which I believe
that is the ones that were saved
in the um end days in the in the
tribulation that were saved during that
time is my question is is that true if
not who are we ruling over all right
during the 10,000 years it says that
they live in reign with Christ let's
just back up a little bit Jesus said I
go and prepare a place for you and if I
go and prepare a place I will come and
receive you that where I am ye may be
the dead in Christ rise when Jesus comes
this is 1 Thessalonians chapter 4 so
when Christ comes we go up and we go to
heaven to the places he's prepared and
then it tells us after that happens we
are living and reigning with Christ for
1,000 years so we've spent 6,000 years
in this world biblically you add up the
ages then we spend a thousand years a
total like 7,000 years living and
reigning with God in heaven we are not
reigning over the wicked because I don't
think any righteous person wants that we
are reigning with Christ Glory you know
there's a very important aspect of
reigning uh when a king was seated upon
his throne and he was reigning was very
often in an act of judgment people would
come with different cases and the king
would judge between different cases
there is a judgment that the Saints are
involved with you reading 1 Corinthians
chapter 6:2 do you not know that the
Saints will judge the world so during
their 1,000-year period the righteous
are in heaven with Christ and they're
involved in the Judgment they're judging
over the wicked now the wicked they they
not raised for this final judgment till
the end of the Thousand Years but the
record of their life is being examined
during this 1,000-year judgment time
period and somehow and the Bible's not
exactly clear but somehow the Saints
have a part in
uh metering out the rewards of the
wicked or the judgments of the wicked
some some degree but that's the type of
reigning that the righteous experienced
during that 10,000 years it's not that
they um you know telling people what to
do on the earth yeah so um we live and
reign with him at the end of the 10,000
years the New Jerusalem comes down from
heaven and U that's when there's a a
great conflict the wicked are all
resurrected says the rest of the Dead
don't live again till the thousand years
are finished and then you've got the
final executive judgment where God
ultimately it's called the white Throne
judgment they are alive and present for
that and he ultimately Reigns fire down
out of Heaven upon them forming a Lake
of Fire
better known as Hellfire uh we have a
lesson that talks about the Thousand
Years and the Millennium and what
happens during that time Jack you would
really enjoy this lesson It lines up all
the scriptures sequentially very clear
when I finally understood this subject
it's just a light went on and the the
final Bible History all eschatology all
made sense to me and that lesson is
called a thousand years of peace and
we'll be happy to send that to anybody
who calls and asks the number is
88356 747 you can ask for the study
guide called a thousand years of peace
and we'll be happy to send that to
anybody who calls and asks and you know
friends why you call our Resource number
I want to remind you you can ask to
enroll in the free amazing facts Bible
study series and we will actually send
you out some of our lessons is a total
of 27 in all but we'll send you out a
few lessons you go through them you'll
actually fill in the little answer sheet
and send it back to us we'll grade it
and send it to the next and it's all
absolutely free that's right
well Pastor Ross I don't know how much
time we got left here oh I have 30
seconds that's not fair to do that to
anybody I don't think we're going to
have time to take another caller and
without cutting them off uh listening
friends if we did not get to your
question tonight don't give up on us
give us another chance next week and for
everybody if you've enjoyed Bible
answers live we have been on the air by
faith and with the help of people like
you there's folks that send donations
some monthly sometimes once a year they
give something to keep us on the air
we'd love for you to be one of those
people and keep us on your station put
us on New stations just go to amazing
facts.org you can donate online and
enjoy the other resources God bless till
next
week thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
Bible even better than before Bible
answers live is produced by amazing
facts a faith based Ministry located in
Sacramento
California amazing facts through your
faithful support has had a major impact
on some of the largest non-Christian
locations in the world Beyond The Great
Wall the printing and translation of our
books and video materials are in
constant
motion the amazing facts Chinese
language website is now one of our most
visited websites we also translated
thousands of pieces of literature for
these nations what started out as
hundreds of followers is now in the
hundreds of thousands the impact of your
funds invested in sharing the
Everlasting gospel in these foreign
lands will be felt for years to come you
know every week we hear the most
incredible stories from all over the
globe of lives that are being changed
and hearts that are being transformed by
the power of the word and none of it
could happen without your teamwork with
this ministry God bless
you I really wanted to start a new
devotional habit but life got in the way
next thing I know we're a month into the
new year and I'm like what's the point
of starting then I saw 365 amazing
answers to Big Bible questions each day
is a single study so you can start
anywhere on any day and not miss a thing
they're crisp clear and
enlightening get yours today by calling
85387 275 or visit AF bookstore.com
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's word visit our website at
www.amazingfacts.org
and sign up for our free Bible study
course and make sure to check out our
online bookstore at AF bookstore.com
which offers thousands of inspiring
books DVDs and more to help you get the
most out of God's word to take advantage
of the offers you've heard on this
broadcast call us at 800 835
6747 or visit our website at
amazingfacts.org did you enjoy this
program make sure to tell your family
and friends tune in next time for more
Bible answers live honest and accurate
answers to your Bible questions
[Music]